[Music]
welcome to the show today I am burning
with excitement because I've managed to
bring onto the show mr. Simon Zushi and
he is just incredible and if it wasn't
for him I probably wouldn't be in
property now because we met maybe 11
years ago and he really encouraged me
right at the beginning but anyway
without further ado Simon welcome to the
show
Samuel thank you very much for asking me
long time I guess yeah I really
appreciate you coming out I mean a
pleasure it's just amazing and you're
here in our offices yep do you like the
offices I'm wonderful yeah great great
so why don't you give a tiny
introduction you might not need one but
who so i started investing in 1995 I
started work at Cadbury's in Birmingham
you know Burma University and had no
money at all because I've been in debt
so my very first house was I bought as a
first-time buyer and I was out to get
95% mortgage but what I had to do was
borrow the 5% deposit and the cost I
didn't have any money so my first deal
was a no money down deal interestingly
and I rented out some of the rooms in my
house two friends who were City
University and the rent they paid me
covered the mortgage in the bill so kind
of live for free so what that meant was
I was able to save the salary from my
job and also I had a part-time business
running student night club events in
Burma missus so 1990 I bought my second
house and I moved from my first one into
my second one and that's really when I
became a proper student Landor 1998 you
know 20 years ago and that's what kicked
it a lot and I had that distinction at
that point that if you buy a property in
the right area at the right price and
you rent it out what happens is when you
take off all the costs the mortgage
insurance the management maintenance and
there's money left over it's like owning
your very own cash machine and if you
have enough of those cash machines it
kind of replaces your income and so I
was able to leave my full-time job at
kbreeze in 2001 by 2003 I've completely
replaced by former income and a passive
basis and then in 2003 I set up the
property investors Network and the
reason I did that was because I started
investing myself in personal development
about the importance of environment
getting white people around you and
went online and there was no kind of
networking for investors and I thought
about you Samuel but I'm sure you will
made lots of mistakes I've made lots of
mistakes and I thought it's got to be
smarter to learn from other people so I
set up the group really the intention of
kind of helping myself really to learn
from other people and connecting and
meeting more people learning about
resources and then people started saying
to me Simon how come you don't have to
work so I started teaching people and
you know old at this point I was
relatively 32 so you're 32
given that work you're 13 you're not
working that's why what what and I mean
I know there's a lot more to the story
but what possessed you to go and buy
your that first property I know there's
no money down but how did you well how
did that happen
I think so odds you know a G so I know
what it was none of my family have ever
been in property apart from their own
homes okay and when I was a student of
Berman University I remember vividly so
I lived in halls of residence I did a
four year course halls for the first two
years thirty I moved out with some
friends into Sally oak which is the main
air and Berman University I remember
walking around Selly Oak in the conative
January looking for houses of students
do to move in for the July and we found
a great house and I found the house so I
got to choose that the the room and I
choose the best room obviously because I
found house it's the perk of taking
action right you know three people are
prepared to take action you've got to be
an action tell you want to be successful
and so I found the house and then we had
to go and meet the landlord at his house
to sign the contracts now he lived in
Edgbaston just around the corner from
our halls Wizards on you probably know
this a very posh Road in Burma called
Farquhar Road yeah very very posh and so
we walked down this this road and this
massive massive house stops it
walked in and you go in the big door and
as you walk in on the left-hand side
there's like a library we went into and
it kind of not quite as big as this room
but similar to this but lined from floor
to ceiling with books and a big big oak
desk and a big chair behind the desk and
four little chairs for us to sit on
right
you knew about negotiation so we sat
down and signed our contract and I
remember saying to the guy at the time I
said what kind of cheeky nineteen year
old I said excuse me I hope you don't
mind me asking what are you do for a
living
and he said well I used to be a
solicitor they're pretty well paid right
but now I'm just a full-time landlord
now I don't think I knew what that
actually meant at the time but later in
that academic year he came round to
house couple times
sort out maintenance or something it was
a full-time looking after the properties
he'd had maintenance guys but he'd come
and manage it and check everything's
going right and I sat down with you a
cup of tea and had a chat with him and
because I've always been an entrepreneur
I like making money and he said he had a
hundred properties in Selly Oak now
that's probably worth about 35 maybe 40
million pounds now and I kind of
realized that what we were paying him
was more than the cost of having the
house and Hadleys properties and he made
money bought more bought more so I think
a seed went into my head yeah and then
and then actually when I came out of
university I was actually employed I did
a four-year combined on his course in
manufacturing engineering Business
Studies great degree from Berman
University a 2:1 came out wasn't a good
time to doing engineering and if I'm
honest I probably didn't put enough
effort into actually applying for a job
so I was busy in my final year so I came
out and that was a real shell shock and
I'd expected to get a good job from a
good degree you know I've come from a
middle-class family my sisters are both
working in big corporates I assumed I
was gonna do that as well
but I just didn't put the effort in but
I needed so I came out I was unemployed
and I remember I just went on a doll for
about six weeks and then I got a
telesales job just joy as employable and
I was living in my old student house in
tainless Road in Selly Oak and it wasn't
great and it was about the time they
started the National Lottery and I
remember this vividly and the reason I'm
telling is because this is really
important back goal setting and
visualization and I I thought what would
I do if I won a million pounds and at
the time I thought I'd buy you know 20
houses and I didn't think about mortgage
I've sought by loan cash and the rental
income we not live on from west of my
life
so it's kind of a vision that I had yeah
from an early well a mid early 20s from
a place of not having any money at all
and being in debt and I kind of thought
what would I do at million powers with
all my land
and it just you know how these bits of a
jigsaw kind of figure together yeah and
I think that's what happened so as soon
as I got a job and as soon as I can get
a job offer I bought a house and I
rented out some of them to my friends
who are still at uni that's such a
brilliant strategy and and 2003 now
you've got a few houses yes alone oh
yeah bit lonely you've got you don't
like to work people are saying you're
not happens to work and what this cuz
all my friends were still at work yeah
so what would you do in the day right
yeah so then you set up the property
investors Network yes just really an
opportunity to people to be able to kind
of come together brainstorm ideas yeah
tell us what happen it's because I know
now pin is massive well you see at the
time I was going to breakfast network
meetings yeah where you know businesses
go and you can connect to other people I
met a great solicitor mortgage broker
account of everything I needed my
property business the problem is none of
them actually had their own properties
so you didn't really understand and you
know what it's like you know friends
like when you get what you want to do
yeah so I wanted that environment and
then so what happened was people said to
me how come you have to work so I
studied explaining what I had done and
realized actually own love to teach and
what I loved Samuel was when I would
share something really simple with
someone they'd go away actually take
action and come back a couple of that's
how I saw this is put it it works on a
board a house and you know then you
could buy anything everyone gone up in
value and you know anybody could borrow
money it was really really easy and I
loved I got addicted if you like to the
feeling of helping other people and the
buzzer would get when people said oh
thank you Simon now they've done the
work but I've been a little bit of a
catalyst in their journey so I started
to teach people in 2003 what I'd done
and had so it was very simple very basic
stuff nothing like the sophisticated
stuff we do right now and people would
come from all over the country they'd
come to Penn and I started pin in London
I mean to Bristol and few other
locations and I was wondering what those
me talk about full meeting it's good
question when you started pinned yeah
you had these few little locations going
on you just started teaching did you
have any idea that come 15 20 years
you'd still be doing it on a massive
level no idea at all I never thought
there'd be I did I didn't have the
vision to have 50 meetings at first when
I started it as we grew it I kind of
thought oh this would be good to have a
a national
network yeah but that wasn't a vision at
first yeah not at all so what happened
how did you go from these few groups
well what happened was I was running the
group's myself yeah which was fine but I
was I was getting a bit tired doing it
and then I'd have people from all over
the country who would come and do some
training with us I do quite I said well
can I set up a group where I live and we
said well yeah okay so if they're done
training done well because to be honest
that I wanted it was a great way to
introduce people to property to give
massive support for them to come and do
some training and and and we don't do a
hard so we don't need to because got so
many proof and track record of results
but people come in meet people to join
our course and we get lots of people
who've done other people's training come
to pin as well that's up to you fine
anyone's welcome but you know even if
you've done of course you know what to
do out there doing it it's really hard
that's where you need support and that's
what we get from pin so these people who
done training with these thoughts is
setting up smaller pins and it's it's
not a franchise there's more partnership
we work together they want to give back
in hell but now 50 amazing people who
host the meetings in their local areas
and and provide that support and what
they get out of it is they are the
center of deal flow they do people come
with money people come with deals and
they have to put a bit of time and
effort in but they kind of want to give
back because they've all done so well
and they want to help other people on
their journey and it's just this
virtuous circle and it it's weird some
people coming and they they think it's a
bit like a cult
behind it because you don't really have
that kind of positive supportive
environments in many places you know
work people are kind of stabbing each
other back and and it's a it's a very
unusual environment yeah it is and and
we met first at property investors
Network we did well I think that must
have been 2007 2008 kind of time just
before the recession I think it was yeah
just around then it must have been end
of 2007 I think I think it was yeah and
I remember you I even I tell the story
the crash courses that I go to because I
remember coming along feeling really
nervous yeah 17 and 17 yeah teenager
just bought a suit that doesn't fit me
properly from Asda yeah and there were
the same ones
and thanks and and we met and you spoke
and I thought wow and that it was that
evening really when I it really just I
thought you know what I think I can do
this yeah you know I just want you to
act a sound say because you know you are
a great speaker and I'm really pleased
I'm not only been successful property
you've kind of followed my footsteps and
you're helping in your inspire up and
that's one of the great things about if
I'm giving a bit of self love here about
mutual love after the suit knock you
need sort the suits out but apart from
that you know but seriously um you know
I think you will understand this what an
amazing feeling that we get yeah when we
know we are inspiring other people
because in a world that is so cynical
and skeptical people don't get it their
condition they have to do a job and
they're gonna they're gonna retire at 67
or 70 they're gonna die very soon after
that there's another way and I think we
can kind of almost shine a light on it
and say hey look you know and it's not
easy you know you've got to put time and
effort in but the time and effort you
put it's going to be so rewarding if we
can inspire people to take action that's
an incredibly rewarding thing and and
you know that because you do that and
and yeah you know I love the way you
speak and you're full of passion and you
spoke lots of pain meetings about
because you helped inspire people so you
know congratulations - thanks I really
appreciate that and you know I think
it's it's great to all the people who've
helped you along the way
you seriously helped me along the way I
remember I share the story at some of
the crash courses but after going to the
pin meeting I remember going home and at
some point the cold reality hit me that
I've got no money I'm too young to even
get a mortgage if I did have money
basically nothing's really nothing's
really for me and I'm thinking this is
stupid maybe I shouldn't have quit my um
you know decided to quit my job maybe
maybe this is a pipe dream and our link
was magic right yes because you used to
also be a magician yes and my dad's a
magician yeah and I was being forced
down the route of working for trading my
time for money yeah very low pay working
as an entertainer yeah and I remember I
don't remember exactly what happened but
we had a 45-minute phone conversation
and I remember that conversation
remember about the
so remember Tony because so I knew your
dad your dad had done some training with
us we taught him how to buy be a mother
that's dad actually yeah so he's that oh
so sorry you slept at my dad was the
mouse so yeah I knew Tim you'll step
down upon okay and and he had done some
training he did 18 I think one of the
very early mastermind program it was
around about same time it was yet we
teach people how to buy parts with none
of our money there's a a creative
mortgage product was in the market at
the time yeah and I remember for some
reason we had that common I don't know
how it came about we had conversation
and and I related it because I at your
age when I was at school I was doing
magic shows yeah I was doing kids
parties I was doing office in the Cambre
and it was good fun and at that age it
was fairly good income as well that that
was great yeah but I said to you Samuel
why are you doing that you're trading
your time for money and and full quit it
to you you got what I was saying yeah
because a lot of people even adults
don't get that message you know I mean
the book I'd obviously recommend that
helps explain it as Rich Dad Poor Dad
yeah you know which I think most people
for tea ready they haven't they should
absolutely read it but it doesn't teach
anything about property really but it's
about mindset and assets and liabilities
and debts and things that's great book
to read but you've got it at a young age
and I said look why are you doing that
you want to buy a property that then
gives you income on going yeah and I
think you took what what your stepdad
was doing and then on what I showed you
and didn't you buy your first property
on your 18th birthday or something just
before my TV birthday yeah yeah yeah and
I think using the no money down yeah
yeah yeah not in my name not using that
strategy
yeah and that was in Bournville we had
also where you yeah well I got my first
HMOs yeah but I think that the big thing
for me on that conversation was was I
was thinking when I'm 17 I don't got any
money or anything but if Simon thinks I
can do it and if he's successful and
he's done it and if he thinks I can yeah
well then I think I can you know so it
was just that belief I think you know
what I think belief is one of the most
important things
yeah and self-doubt is what stops a lot
of people actually achieving their
dreams and you know if we can help
inspire people yeah and I say that and
give them no leaf you believed in me
well I now believe in other people
absolutely
we all believed in one another I believe
anyone can do it anyone could become
successful in property but they've got
to want to do it and they'll have a
reason why and they've got to be
prepared to put the effort unfortunate
with too many people who want to get
rich quick who are not prepared they go
on a training program as if it's like a
lottery ticket or something exactly
which we do make me rich maybe rich yeah
it's not gonna happen is that amazing
you know how long will it take you to
make me financially free I said it
wouldn't happen yes give you the tools
yeah because I'll do it yourself exactly
accepting personal responsibility for
anything you do in your life it's
critical to your success so that's what
happened next them so 2007 2008 you run
in these networks you've got a giant
company you aggressively building your
own property portfolio yeah you're
financially free yeah what's happened
since then what about what do you do now
so um I still teach because I love
teaching and we still have when I'm
asked my program and the investment to
do my smile has gone up significantly
because we put coaching in and mentoring
all the things that weren't there in the
early days when you stepdad did it and
it's interesting sometimes get people
folks silikal say oh well if you're so
good at property why are you teaching
people how to do it won't just do
property and and here's the thing that
people need to understand when you make
a lot of money it's not about the money
when you make a lot of money you have
choice and freedom to do what you want
to do and if I had to choose property or
teaching people how I would always
choose teaching people what is great I
still invest in property I think it's
important to keep up to date because the
markets concentrated that's why keep on
updating my book because the markets
changing but and there are some great
opportunities out there so why wouldn't
I do it but if I had to choose it would
be training because that's what I'm
passionate I love seeing people change
and you know inspiring a 17 year old kid
you now goes inspires other people
what's the ripple effect that I can have
on life I can impact far more people
than just buying property and I think we
need to you know fulfill your purpose
about what are you really here for and I
don't if I'm doing what my purpose is
but I think I'm as close to it as I can
be at the moment till I work out what
else I'm gonna do yeah and so you know
that's the thing
yes property is great but I believe most
people investment property isn't because
they want the property or even the
income it's what the income allows
to do yeah cuz when you got the income
coming in it frees up your time you
could choose what you want and I choose
to teach people and interesting lease
episode water you do it for free well I
have done a lot of training and I do a
lot of stuff for free but I absolutely
know when something's for free
unfortunately most people won't value it
and you know what someone I'm sure you
said the more we charge the better
results my students get because they've
got skin in the game yeah and they have
to make it work because they've invested
good money yeah so I generally don't do
free events because although some people
will get it and run for it unfortunately
people if I know you give such a
valuable information on your crash
course some people just don't they just
don't take it do you think with it
because it's free they don't value it
that's so true and I remember thinking
when I started out in property I
remember thinking I wonder why Simon
teaches you know I know I was one of
those people that used to think that
much money in property I didn't get it
yeah but now I really do get it because
I think as you say when you've when
you're financially free what next
exactly and and and and it's people who
are stuck in a job who don't have enough
money who think like that they thought
about money it's not about money once
you've got money you don't have freed I
mean well take the money don't get me
wrong you know I like I'm not
particularly flash person I don't drive
fast cars or anything but you know I
like lots of holidays I like lifestyle
experience yeah and and I think anyone
who says money is wrong has not given
enough of it away yeah very true very
true
umm tell us a little bit about - you
know right now we're at the back end of
2018 yes there's a lot of uncertainty
going around twenty fours coming in yeah
brexit who the heck knows what's going
on with that at the moment yeah but
people are very scared
they are very people are selling their
portfolios yeah people are there's just
a lot of confusion going on yeah do you
think now is a good time or a bad time
to invest in property okay that's an
excellent question so it's a good time
but there are a couple of conditions one
is if you know what you're doing okay
let's we make I'm gonna make a little
prediction here and I think this is not
widely outrageous what I'm about to say
I believe we're going to see a dip in
property prices
2019 we were only singing back in the
2018 and it may well continue in 2020 I
don't think we're gonna see a crash but
I might be wrong okay but guess what the
general perception is there could be a
massive crash if there's no deal on the
29th of March when the UK is supposed to
leave Europe the European Union okay and
it's interesting the governor of the
Bank of England's Mark Carney made a
presentation a speech about what could
happen if there's no deal and he said it
could be an economic crisis like 2008 so
that's what he said he was actually
misquoted in many of the national
newspapers who said house prices could
crash 35% now in 2008 the worst case
scenario was a 35% crash place like
Northern Ireland who shot up massively
in the mid two thousands way too much
and then they crashed down most places
in UK crashed about 20 to 25 percent but
what that was caused by was because the
banks had realized I had all this toxic
debt and they'd made loads of people
there they're never gonna get the money
back from you know you may remember this
in in 2006-2007 you could get vital
acknowledges up to 90 percent loan to
value you could get home mortgages for a
hundred and twenty five percent of the
purchase price and I've published to
have two hundred thousand you could get
a two hundred fifty thousand pound
mortgage two hundred white house fifty
thousand to go on a holiday bar card to
whatever you want to do so a lot of
people putting themselves into negative
debt and the banks realized they had
massively there was irresponsible
lending and irresponsible borrowing so
what happened was 2008 it was actually
really hard to borrow money to buy so
the people who wanted to buy people
couldn't buy people couldn't sell prices
crashed down so those circumstances not
the same that the toxic debt doesn't
exist we're not to the same extent it
used to banks have not lent such high
loads of money there's more equity in
there so the banks could with with
stands a drop of 35 percent in property
prices and still be okay he wasn't
saying that was going to happen I don't
think that would happen but what what I
think what you think what people
watching this doesn't really matter it's
all about the general public perception
so what that means is if the general
public people trying to sell properties
think prices could crash as much as 35%
this next six months from right now
until the end of March and depends upon
people watching this video but there is
an unprecedented opportunity I believe
an opportunity of a lifetime if you know
what you're doing to get out there and
get some really good deals now if you
are buying now you have to accept that
you might buy now and it could be worth
a little bit less in six months time so
if you are buying to do up and sell on
flipping property that would not be a
good strategy if Boise is going to come
down but if you're looking to hold for a
long time and if you follow my five
golden rules I talked about in my book
property magic while you always bind an
average strong rental demand rule number
two you always buy for positive cash
flow so it gives you profit every month
and rule number four you always buy for
a long term so if you follow those rules
and you're blind for a long term and
it's making cash flow and you can easily
rent it out it doesn't matter if prices
are slightly lower than where you bought
it because over the long term in the UK
property prices go up because we live in
an island with a limited supply of
accommodation and an increasing
population so over a long term property
prices go up even if when the UK come
out breaks it if they pull up the
drawbridge and flood the tunnel and
don't let anyone else into the UK we
will still have an increasing population
because of increasing birth rates and
increasing life expectancy we're living
longer so the population going up and a
limited supply of space long term rents
and prices should go up and also if all
these landlords and not everyone but a
lot of landlords who may be thinking
about retiring they might be investing
for 10-15 years and they're thinking you
know what because of section 24 which is
where investors get taxed in a different
way now and from April 2017 when it
first came in phased over four years by
2020 if you own props your own name and
your high rate taxpayer you will pay a
lot more tax on your property portfolio
such that if you've got high mortgages
and also if interest rates go up you
might have properties that don't
actually make you any money but on paper
they make a profit which means you have
to reach into your pocket it takes money
to pay the tax man each year that is not
a good asset to hold so I think we're
gonna see a lot of investors sell their
property
that's why a lot of what's gonna come
into the market that's why price of a
dip by the way if they're not renting
their property there's less rental
property available so those of us who
are in the market still should see rents
go up so it's amazing how all these
factors kind of work together to create
this unique opportunity but I really do
think now is always a good time to
invest something you're doing but right
now is just an opportunity probably of a
lifetime yeah what do you think about
that all I think you're absolutely right
and I think that I mean with the new tax
changes one of the things that I'm
seeing is it's not easy to switch your
individual properties over to a limited
company that's correct so what's
happening is people are either taking
the hit like me properties that I own is
an individual I've worked out it's gonna
cost me about 30 40 quid a month on
average per property yeah because
they're just little cheap houses so
that's not really a big egg the more
expensive properties or if people have
really burns then they're gonna they're
gonna sell up yeah or they're going to
put their rent up yeah so what's gonna
happen it and both of those things mean
opportunity for us absolutely so and I
think rent certainly in the Midlands
have gone up quite quite a lot yeah
now the properties that I'm buying now
I'm buying through a company so the tax
changes don't even apply yeah
moving forward I'm doing the same thing
yeah so I'm buying the company so the
tax changes don't apply well I'll still
benefit from the rent increase exactly
so and you'll also benefit from more
landlord looking to sell who might be
panicking cuz a brexit and you'll be
able to pay less over the next six
months than you did if you bought a
couple months ago exactly I think we're
in T right yeah absolutely and I think
wherever there's a wherever there's a
rule change there's always something
else there's always like for instance
when they change the tax that's
tempering section 24 very very quickly
they change the rules on buying a
company didn't they so they said you
made it very easy to sell us a company
in buy house to it yeah immediately so
yeah I think it's a massive opportunity
and it's interesting you know what when
you know we are always going to see
change as landlords we need to expect
accept that yeah and embrace it and you
know you get some people who don't have
the right mindset who moaning and look
don't get me wrong section 24 isn't what
a good thing for landlords
and I'm very surprised by a Conservative
government bringing something like that
in and I think it's because they want to
they don't really want individuals to
have properties they want to make it
corporates because they think they can
legislate easier you can collect tax
easier if it's a corporate rather than
it is a there's a reason they're doing
it okay but things happen and we always
need to look for the silver lining and
it's about having the right positive
mindset saying there's always a way to
get that no one else is panicking yeah
if you know what you're doing you can
make a real opportunity do you think
there's a chance the moleish section 24
very possibly so they introduced it in
Ireland I think about nine ten years ago
and then or maybe slightly longer and
then they abolished it after about nine
years mmm so that could happen they
could realize that actually because you
know there could be a real issue if
there's not enough incentive for private
landlords to have properties and people
start selling up rents are going to go
up and affordability of a problem and
actually there could be a real issue
that there's just not enough
accommodation so what's going to happen
guess what the council's gonna have more
people they've got a supply
accommodation for they don't have enough
housing they could be some real issues
that the government has not fought
through here yeah and it takes time for
those to filter through which would
massively increase rents it would
massively increase rents yeah so you
know there are some there was some long
term implications and I think what
happened the Chancellor at the time went
into his local tax office and saw that
some property investor was earning
hundreds of thousands of pounds a year
and not paying any tax because as we
know there are some very clever things
you can do legitimately using the rules
to minimize your tax and you know if you
want to be wealthy that there's there's
three things you need to know how to one
is you got to learn how to make money
and that's great but most people stop
there second thing is you gotta learn
how to keep your money and a lot of that
is understanding how taxation works and
make the most of the laws to your
advantage because it's the rich people
make tax laws not the poor people and
then the third thing is you need to know
how to grow your money now actually
Popat you can do all of those for you
you can make money from it you can
minimize your tax in certain ways and
you could grow it so that's why property
is such a great investment vehicle but
you know you've got to understand that
most people have a very limited mindset
and when a change comes along they don't
like change
and I have to adapt and if we want to be
professional investors we just need to
adapt to get on them and find the
opportunity yes always there I usually
say when there's a scary news report
about property or something your instant
reaction should be to up your hands
together exactly yeah because there's
always money to make that happen and you
look that's why I don't think you should
read the news or listen to the news on
the radio or read the paper because
watch TV because it's always negative
yeah you know if you want to be a
successful person don't fill your head
with all that negativity you should
listen to audiobooks of successful
people or property books or or listen to
audio from property courses whatever
listen to all of that stuff to put
positivity into your head to reinforce
it yes you can do this and make sure
you're not like the average person yeah
brilliant then ask a couple of questions
firstly some people watching this
economy people that have got money yeah
and they're looking to dump ninety
property and invest that yes what advice
what would you do right now if you had
say 100 grand in the bank
yeah you're wanting to invest it where
where would you put that and what would
you do with that moment okay well it's
very easy for me given what I know now
but I'd say the most important thing is
make sure you educate yourself because
any idiot can buy a property and many
idiots do buy property okay so I would
want to make sure I know what is a good
deal first of all then I'd want to find
an area and personally if I was doing
that and I trained myself I'd probably
want to invest something like HMOs
houses a Multiple Occupation yeah I feel
that in many areas there is an
oversupply of HMOs but actually most
HMOs are not very good condition our
students have really high-end HMOs they
get much higher rate than most people
yeah there's there's not a shortage of
good tenants who want to live in those
properties so don't compete on price a
so it's a bad thing to do okay and they
produce really good cash flow and if
there is an economic turndown by the way
people can't afford to live on their own
in an apartment anymore going into an
HMO shared house is actually a more cost
effective thing to do so actually I
think it's future-proof and also in
addition to that HMOs are a highly
regulated market they change all the
regulations in beginning of October 2018
and a lot of people panicking about that
but again just got
to move on um but there's gonna be no
major changes because they were already
highly regulated
whereas I mean service accommodation is
a very popular strategy I think it's got
a few challenges with leases and things
in apartments at times but it's a great
strategy my one concern with that
strategy is it is completely unregulated
and it's probably the most likely thing
that could become highly regulated and
some people who've built a whole
business around that could have the
whole business wiped out yeah so I think
it's always good to diversify and put
your money in different things but my my
money would still be going into HMOs
okay it's really interested in what
about if you're watching this video and
you haven't got any money at all I know
you're someone who personally has bought
properties of Nome and I have someone
that also preaches that and has seen
many people do that me too
yes what would you say to someone that
didn't have any money okay well it's
always easier if you have money
obviously but what you need to
understand is if you don't have money
the very best thing you can do is get
good at finding great deals yes because
there are plenty of people who have got
money and don't have the time the
knowledge or even the inclination or
desire to find properties themselves so
what you could do is you could actually
find deals and sell them to other people
package deals with that way of doing it
and the problem is most people who come
in they think I've not got a lot of
money I'll package deals but they waste
so much of their time because what
they've got unknot deals because they
haven't educates us to work out what
makes a good deal they don't know how to
package it right so that that's the
first thing cell deals the other thing
is you could also instead of selling
those deals get other people who want to
come in as a joint venture so you might
find a deal do all the work someone else
got the money they don't want to get
involved they put the cash and you have
some sort of split of the cash flow and
the future equity growth so that's a
great strategy better than that
I think is if we get private loans from
people and that's where instead of
getting a share of the equity they get
just a guaranteed fixed return and you
know sometimes it's easier I'll give you
half the profits it might be easy to get
that then get a interest rate so a way
of building your credibility by getting
loans is do do something like venture
so when to rent is where you find maybe
a landlord they've got a property maybe
they're a distant landlords maybe
they've had some challenges and they're
just fed up or they're retiring you can
take their property on you can rent it
out and very very quickly you enter out
in a different way to them so it might
be a single act that you could do a
service accommodation or it might be a
larger house you can use an HMO or might
be already an HMO that they're strike to
let for some reason and if you can fix
that problem take it on and you get the
margin but what you between what you pay
the landlord and what you pay about the
tenants pay you and so that's a great
way of making money on a property you
don't even own one step better than
events of rent is a purchase lease
option which one of my favorite
strategies where you get to control the
property you get the benefit of cash
flow and you have the right to buy the
property in the future at a price you
fixed today so you get cash flow and
potential exit to go from a property
yeah without a mortgage without a big
deposit it all comes down to education
and these are these strategies are they
just oh yeah in sound good in theory or
these real things that these doing now
things we've got people doing right now
we got so much evidence yeah I got
people doing in the market but bills
like oh that doesn't work where I live
well that's rubbish
you know I got people doing options
we've got a lady I've just finished our
mastermind program she's lived in London
she's buying in London she's got an
option on three apartments in Docklands
she used service combinations just next
to Excel the conference center
year-round business um it's just over a
million pounds of property she would
have had to put two hundred and fifty
three hundred thousand in to actually
buy those but she has put some money in
it she couldn't do it no money down but
she's getting fifty five thousand pound
profits profit after all expenses a year
that's incredible you know in London so
these strategies work everywhere
somewhat better in certain in who's all
always you can either make excuses or
you can make money right no there's a
great saying by Henry Ford yeah he said
if you believe you can I believe you
can't you're absolutely right yeah and
if you don't think there are great deals
in your area guess what you're
absolutely if you don't think there are
options in your air you're absolutely
you'll never do them yeah someone
someone said to me I'll no money down
deals aren't possible and I said you
absolutely right they're not possible
for you yeah that's right you know
people don't like that I'd like no but
yeah it's it's there's no point arguing
with idiots just make two idiots yeah
you might sort of create new actually
why you're never gonna find them what
would be your give me some advice that
you don't usually share something that
people probably haven't heard before so
it made me follow you I I pretty much
tell everyone what to do
I'm like it did simple I said though
simple things you just go and do this
stuff yeah just like I swim it a little
bit background sort of some some inside
knowledge some new strategy new tip
something new well I mean put you on the
spot talk about hot off the press is the
opportunity right now but yeah brexit
and the uncertain yeah yeah one of my
clients you know when they had the
referendum in 2016 yeah the the
marketing in London I'm very very soft a
lot people were really worried cuz you
know what's going to happen okay and one
more clients was very very wealthy she
was looking to buy properties in London
and she found a property in a square
that she really really likes and she
wants to live there herself it was on
the market for seven million pounds okay
so she very wealthy lady buying cash yes
old a an IT business and I'm using what
we taught her and using the fact that
the seller was really worried about
what's going to happen she was able to
buy for cash three weeks before brexit
and got twenty one percent discount in
prime London save one and a half million
pounds forty four five and a half
minutes that is seven half million well
it's about timing yeah and and timing is
right now and and a tip I will give you
assure you know this is what's called
speed of implementation successful
people we hear something we we then go
and employ it straightaway
yeah I'm not saying you should do
everything because you'll hear some
things that maybe don't necessary got to
find the strategy that works for you
based on your time your resources etc
but the really important thing is that
when you learn something don't think
about you know the strategy that I
taught you back in 2007 that helped you
buy that first property but now have
your own money by mid 2008 you couldn't
do that strategy anymore as the Morgan
mortgage market changed so if you'd sit
around thinking oh I'm just seventeen I
can't buy property or this doesn't work
I'll do it when I'm older guess what
you wouldn't be able to do it
but only because you took action at the
time and we inspired you and I believed
in you and you believed in yourself when
I did it you got the results because you
took action yeah that's so true that's
some of that speed of implementation
we've just had one of our students who
two days after a read deserves two
accommodation event went and secured a
deal when it's not two days exactly but
that's what they should do what houses
people get the manual they write the
notes they put it on the shelf and okay
I'll do that next month I don't know do
it straightaway yeah
clear it time in your diary so here's
another tip for you you might have a B
action list of all the things you need
to do which is great you're to work out
what to do and prioritize them a lot of
people tick off the easiest thing first
do the most important thing first but
also schedule time in your diary to
actually get things done if I enjoy what
am I gonna do when I have this time and
that's where you should prioritize this
because otherwise you'll never get
around to it
yeah that's so true Simon totally what
about your book because I mean you've
written a book and the annoying thing is
is my books property bestseller yeah
they keeps getting beaten by your book
yeah it does yeah have you seen my book
beat your book as well your book yeah it
look at someone's ahead of me are we are
we are justly yeah we do yeah I think
you're number one at the moment so
congrats today I am yes yeah I'd rather
I'd rather someone like you know what
helped you on this one I don't know yeah
that's a I'd rather someone like you
those as well so what was the question
again so the question was tell me why
your book is so good because it
sometimes beats my book right okay yeah
so my book is so good for a number of
reasons
yeah first of all thicker than mine well
well it's a sixth edition yeah well hey
yeah so I believe it's right now I I've
only read I haven't read your whole book
I must submit a part part write it okay
it's very long I understand okay so I'm
not ready all but I don't know if it's
at all dated because I give some very
specific information in here so when I
first did it for example chapter 2 was
all about right
Harry use more to express step bust
exactly what do you do to buy pot using
their very money I published it in
February 2008 I voted back in a 2007 by
May 2008 more just better stop doing
that product so chapter 2 was
obsolete now the rest of the book was
still bad about how you find motivated
sellers Howdy's other who was money for
this obsolete so I then thought I could
do it so I bought out or another edition
and every time now reluctant to bring
out a new edition because every time I
bring something out something changes so
the last edition number five was in July
2015
two weeks later the government announced
the plans for section 24 a thing our god
it's all changed so I waited a little
bit that's brilliant know that you you
keep updating it and I think some people
stopped Edition like there's some books
that's what Robert Kiyosaki so clear
though because Rich Dad Poor Dad you
don't need to change it but no exact but
with your book I mean some people call
my book and I think yours is similar
almost like the follow-on from Rich Dad
Poor Dad
absolutely read Rich Dad Poor Dad you
have your mindset changed you realize
about passive income all the things you
can do
yes our books are kind of like the ABC
yeah we just said Poor Dad doesn't
really teach you much about it changes
your thinking and then it lines you up
to be ready but that's why I read your
book he doesn't need to keep changing it
no exactly we do yeah we're specific
about what's happening in the market and
what you need to do you know an HMO
regulations of things change exams so so
I think my book does so well for a
couple of reasons first of all it's
updated which is really important
secondly it's actually very simple yeah
I try it when I teach and I know you do
this as well several I try and make
things really simple so people could
actually follow it there are some people
who teach who like to make things
complicated rate yourselves look clever
yeah look property is actually
straightforward I don't think is easy
but it's straightforward it's step by
step by step and I try and break it down
so that people can get it the other
thing I do in the book you know you
can't teach everything in a book that's
why we want courses right but I I like
to inspire people and give them the
belief and open their mind and expand
their horizons about what's actually
possible brilliant yeah and that's what
I think people get about Tony Robbins
says that complexity is the thief of
execution absolutely and it's it's any
idiot can make something complicated
yeah but it takes a genius to make
something complicated simple yeah and I
think one of the reasons although I've
loved doing going on some of your
seminars is because you make things very
simple yeah tell us a little bit about
how people would get in touch I mean I
imagine the best way would be to go to
go along to one of your prop
mr. network meetings yes so we've got
pig meetings around the country the
website that is pin meeting PN meeting
her at UK and then go along and actually
it's 20 pounds to go along but as we're
here together Samuel why don't we give
people an offer if they put in we have
lots of voucher case leads SS Leeds
so s Leeds will set up as a batch code
security come along
oh is it right some of us to come along
then come to their first meeting as your
guests completely free of charge for
watching this video
there we go just to check it out and see
if they like you I'll just say I mean
the pin meetings are brilliant and
thanks I used to go religiously a couple
times a month for years and there's a
real real support to me and then I
started speaking at them you spend like
some meetings I probably spoken it maybe
20 yeah
I hope you do that through it for it for
a while now but they're a brilliant
place to be and yes it's been awesome
having you on the show thank you I'm
really also connecting me on LinkedIn
yeah well my surname is uchi Zed UT Shi
and going by the book obviously it's a
really one audio as well because a lot
people prefer to listen so we just put
out the 6th edition on audible and you
know got a great let me ask you one more
question are you going to be watching my
financial freedom challenge I am we
spoke about that earlier Samuel and I
think that's I think it's really good
because you're right a lot of people
think oh I can't I can't invest in but
I've got no money and they're missing
the point that as I said if you find
good deals you know you will find money
and we were talking I think you made it
very I'll be really honest here I think
you made it really hard for yourself
some of the rules you set I think you
can't use your name you can't have any
help from your team so I think you've
set it up it is a genuine challenge and
I I'm sure that with enough time so
let's say someone was doing a job to
keep them going but they had no extra
money with enough time they could do it
you've made it really honkers you giving
yourself a short amount of time so you
and I know with persistence
anybody can get that if they're doing
the right things but I think particular
cause you got a time limit on it I will
look with interest and you know you know
because we've spoke off-camera I'm
genuinely scared about the challenge I
know because it's come it's real as real
that's great it is real and it's a
genuine challenge I applaud you and
you know I probably wouldn't do it
thanks so much see so thank you Samuel
Cheers thank you so much for watching if
you benefited from that video please do
share it with your family and friends
for more videos like it you can watch
right here and if you'd like to spend
two days with me at the property
investors crash course watch this video
see what happens but whatever you do
don't forget to subscribe right here and
I'll see you next time